gets every single ounce of the delicious
goodness that is SCP containment breach
now hello hi welcome back to SCP
containment breach and welcome back to
the newly updated version of it this is
version 1.3 point seven which have you
been following I believe the last time I
played this was probably either version
1.1 or version 1.2 or maybe even 1.0 so
it's been a long long time since I
played this game and it's uh it's been
comfortably a while since I've done it
so hopefully you guys can see me and
everything that's going on so welcome
good morning everybody how are you doing
welcome to SCP containment breach
hope you guys are doing a wonderful time
this is live in case you were wondering
yes I can see your chat right there yes
it started a little bit earlier than the
scheduled time I meant to get this out a
little earlier but I had some technical
difficulties and also I was warming up
my voice because if you were watching
the most recent mortem for some reason
my voice has been very fragile lately
and it's been a little bit tender so I'm
getting back into the swing of things
and I'm gonna be starting out with SCP
containment breach and we're gonna be
going in very short order but I'm gonna
be starting the actual game in about
seven minutes or six minutes as soon as
it hits 10:30 that's when I'm actually
gonna be getting into the game so in the
meantime just welcome how you doing if
you've got questions for me please type
them in the chat below I will try to
answer them Abbess I can't even though
they're going holy hell fast so if you
guys are there let me see you talk give
me some Aussies bunch of hay and hi so
hello everybody hi hi hi hi oh my god oh
my god is this all you got huh is this
all the Chad you got huh this is really
it come on lay it on me hey you gotta
have more than this here oh yeah that's
better
that's more like it yeah oh you like
more time oh good it was a little it was
a little janky that's definitely to be
sure but hopefully hopefully it'll get
better because I like the hide-and-seek
aspect of it it was just a bit a little
bit too constrained by the faulty doors
to be 100% but this game
this game is not constrained by faulty
doors unless the faulty doors are there
to screw you over which oftentimes they
are make a dick joke I don't want to
make a dick joke yeah slow mode
unfortunately I know you guys are here
and you're chatting up a storm but slow
mode is the only way that we can get any
semblance of order here and also prevent
a little bit of spam so hopefully you
guys can put up with that for the time
being I think it's only thirty seconds
so if you need to say things within 30
seconds man you guys are going way
faster than I am but I'm gonna join in
here I'm gonna sit here hello it's B
it's B you guys I said hi even though
it's gone immediately it's gone up and
out of here so anyway just five more
minutes so if you've got questions for
me write out in full complete sentences
whether your questions are even though
they're going so fast yeah I know
oh there's my message oh man now even
that was delayed holy hell yeah well
thank you thank you so much I think I
saw that that it was either I love your
videos or I [ __ ] hate your videos I
can't tell which one that was actually
that but I'm gonna assume that no matter
what you guys said I'm gonna thank you
nonetheless because I appreciate that oh
yeah this is the the VidCon last year's
VidCon shirt so uh I tore the sleeves
off to make way for my impressive
musculature which is not as impressive
as it used to be but hopefully it'll get
there again because I've I found that
the most enjoyable thing that I could be
doing is trampolining and that may sound
silly but if you've ever gone to a like
us sky Zone I think it's called I'm not
promoting sky Zone there's a lot of
competitors in fact I've actually never
been to a sky Zone I've been to a lot of
the other versions because every time
I've gone to a sky Zone they've been
closed or they turn me away at the door
so coudair anywhere else but sky Zone
anyway but so it's a trampoline gym that
just has a bunch of trampolines in the
floor and you bounce from bounce and
then they got obstacle courses and cool
[ __ ] like that it's super fun and I
like it so I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
doing that
and then I'm gonna be getting back into
rock climbing again because that's
something I fell out of that was really
fun it's just been super busy this past
time trying to prep for this show yeah
anyway thanks again everybody and Oh max
Levine says are you going to be doing
the game all in one sitting or starting
up a new series for this after the
stream a good question I would like to
do a new series of this game if it so
calls for that I just thought I'd do a
live stream could kind of get into it
because there's so many new things in
the game then I'm not 100% sure what I
should do or what I shouldn't do um
let's see Drako 1 to 8 408 says love you
mark your damn awesome keep doing your
beautiful work you amazing man oh thank
you so much I really do appreciate that
so I'm gonna be trying to do that as
best I can and then then hopefully
hopefully I'll have something more to
show for it later and then maybe we'll
have a series at the end of the day I
don't know it's really weird because
considering SCP containment breach is
one of my longer running series I think
it's been overtaken by subnautica
recently but it is definitely one of my
longer running series with how many how
many goddamn videos of that did I play
cuz I played it for years because it
updated all the time in the initial
phase and I still say to this day I
still say gosh darn it you guys at
undertale games charge money for it it's
so good you've put so much work into it
I mean I know it's been free this whole
time but you really oh man whoa oh holy
crap hang on guys whoa whoa all right
okay there's a lot of messages here
queued up so first up pvp hacker says
I've been watching you since 3 million
thank you guys so much for being here
with me so long
Joey dogs high-five mark top of the
mornin dia Jason Worley says you are
amazing and you inspire me every day I
this is the new super chat feature that
they put in that I I actually had no
idea how it even works but anyway thank
you so much Jason Worley for
for being here and end and watching the
videos and I really appreciate it for
what it is and then Isaiah angle Marxist
thank you mark for the years I've been
subscribed to you you helped me through
a lot of my depression I'm really happy
to help you guys out and I mean in a way
that sounds weird for me to say like I'm
happy to help you guys out I'm happy
just to make videos every day and be
here with you guys so I just wanted to
say how important that is to me and
being here with you guys for this
adventure and it's almost time to start
yeah 48 videos 48 videos technically
fifty three if you count there was a
long time ago
the quiz' there was a My Little Pony mod
for SCP containment breach that I played
I did a five episode series on that and
that was a very controversial series
because I am NOT a brony or anything to
that sort but man people were all up in
arms about me playing on My Little Pony
mod of it I just thought it'd be funny
to see these like these horrifying
things you know in a pony world but if
you count those at 53 videos but if you
don't count those which I'm totally like
you're totally okay with it because it's
in a completely separate playlist that
does exist though alright and then
hayden salmon says haymarket love you so
much can you read this out I love you so
much well I just did that so thanks
again thanks thanks Hayden and Jesse
Lomas says Mark man I've been watching
you since the early days but I always
miss your live streams cuz I'm in
Australia well you made it to this one
so I really do appreciate it
glamor and gaming said thank you for
being here through the dark times I love
you mark and Jake Kim if you scream
marry me well get ready because I'm
pretty sure this game is gonna cause me
to scream involuntarily and then Bethany
Thomas says hi gets so excited when I
see your live stream so with that being
said I'm not gonna let anything else get
in the way of it we're about to start in
a new game and is that a good map seed
that I like because you get random map
seeds now and I don't know if they're
actually gonna make any different Larry
that seems like a very dangerous one I'm
also gonna put it on Euclid so I'm gonna
call this one marquee mu all right now
I'm gonna call this one Larry
this one's Larry Larry lots of Larry
I'm gonna be involved with Larry a lot
no intro sequence because we've already
seen it hasn't changed have her checked
it out so yeah oh not our mesh did it
cry well that crashed well that's good I
thought they worked out the bugs to this
one but apparently not let me try that
again maybe Larry Larry isn't the best
one to have and give me a give me a hot
second here getting it back yeah like I
said the gum of the gum the game oddly
enough has still a few bugs to work out
CT money game excel
mark your mere inspiration of the game
and have fun with content creation and
strive to good in the world keep it up
and looking forward to your next charity
livestream which is coming we are doing
one this month we just got to figure out
when we can do that memoir IANA said I
fell in love with the new subnautica
series but I still don't understand your
view of the ocean understand it what's
to understand it's terrifying that's
really all there is to understand about
it let's see see hello mark where did
chicas name come from is it from finale
enough no chica it's just more of a
coincidental thing because her her name
before I got her was Sephora and so I
changed her name because I didn't want
to be calling out a brand of makeup as
good or bad as it may be but I just
wanted to do that because it was
important that I I changed that for me
and then I wanted to name her so chica
it's important when you name a dog the
end of the name be the same the
beginning of the name is not entirely
important but it's really the end of the
name that they respond to so it's very
important a man's Jay says any tour news
you can talk about again my dark blue
shirt and it fits amazing well thank you
so much for buying that I'm glad you got
that that shipped out in good timely
order no tour news yet I will let you
guys know we're still looking at the
beginning of June we just don't know the
specific dates yet let's see Jen you
says working on an animation it's best I
can do for repaying to repay for
cheering me up in the hospital oh I hope
you're doing better thanks so much for
making a a
an animation for me Fox's places thank
you Mark
Rohr Jenkins says thank you for being
you mark it's so funny to watch them not
again because my name is Aurora so you
can do me a favor and say hello Aurora
okay hello Aurora how you going
Ashley's Juarez says I always admired
you Marc not to furry looks but to your
personality and morale and hope to
follow your example love you much okay
I'll get to these messages very soon
there are ton of them but I want to get
back into the game and make sure that
this actually works so I'm a call it's
what Marc EMU and hopefully Larry isn't
gonna destroy me come on now come on now
Oh what is going on
it worked I just loaded this game up I
literally just loaded this game up and
it worked fine all right well hang on
one second I'm gonna be right there
where I'm not gonna give up on this
we're gonna get this definitely cuz so
long as I'm here I did I'm gonna try to
load up the game that I did I know for a
fact works because if I can get that
then I'm definitely gonna get that oh my
goodness there's so many um I didn't
realize that so many people would be
using the super chat function oh that's
a little disconcerting this place will
burn that's it's not a good sign
Oh Frick I didn't save the game let me
try one more time uh Jeffrey Blatt
damnit okay let me try I can try to
update the game because there's an
option to update the game right before
it goes so let me just try to update it
and while it's updating I'm gonna try to
read more of these messages because
there's so many of them I did not I did
not even think that there was gonna be
that many messages but thank you guys so
much I'm gonna try to read them as best
I can
right here I've got another way to do it
let's see
so many of these okay gentry a butler
says please don't die this time no
promises
can't even begin to promise that one
because I'm pretty sure I'm gonna die
literally non-stop no matter what I do
Tori Ryan says I've been here since two
million you've helped me daily oh man
there's a there's a very personal story
in there and I don't want to read it out
loud to you guys but I just want to say
I hope you're doing okay now and I'm
glad that my videos could give you a
laugh when you need it the most so
that's that's uh I'm really happy that I
can help him whatever way yeah so um
let's see Korey Wagoner said your SCP
videos have always been one of my
favorites in this new feature must be
the new spangled thing to be competitive
to twitch yeah I suppose it is YouTube
wants to be a little bit more more
involved in it yeah so thank you guys so
much for being a part of this and yeah
it really it really doesn't mean a lot
that you guys are here on this stream
and I will be I'll be there soon come on
it's almost done downloading the update
and I'm gonna get there just in just a
gosh-darn second Joseph Wheelock says
hey Mark I love your videos and I hope
you keep inspiring people to do happy to
be happy and do great things
thank you so much Mitchell Rowling says
3:30 4:00 a.m. and I'm pumped you're an
inspiration to many love your work dude
how many people are watching from
international right now if you're if
you're outside of the US even if you're
in Canada or something like say so and
chat because I really do want to know
like how many people are actually out
and about I'm assuming that's from
Australia or something because oh man
there are so many people around here so
man it's it's a darn shame because even
with super chat enabled there's so many
messages that's really hard to get to
all of them
spicy brownie mix 101 said you really
inspired me I know it's not much but I
hope it helps oh thank you so much Jui
okay there we go
Jamin holly said the super chat feature
is awesome it allows anyone with money
to be seen any way mark when will you
come to Canada specifically Toronto I
will I will think about doing a two
or in Canada after we do the initial run
in the US because what I want to do is I
want to be here in the in the in the US
and the beginning just so we can plan
out and do a better stream initially and
then later on we'll go out and move on
into Canada and I see tons of people are
saying Canada Germany Puerto Rico I saw
that Sweden I saw a lot of people from
Australia France Scotland Greece Greece
Wow
more Puerto Rico Denmark Egypt hell yeah
and then India Norway it's Las Vegas
yeah that's outside the US practically
yeah pretty much I'm gonna assume that
that's not part of the US alright so I'm
gonna try the scan it's done updating if
this can work let's see Ben Davies will
you do a full playthrough a full
throttle remastered I don't even know
what that is what is that what is full
throttle dream master
all right hang on let's try this one
more time if this works I'm gonna be
very happy okay of course one ah Billy
put it on Euclid go
[Music]
Oh didn't I was about to hang up there
it's about to freeze but I think we got
it I think we got it with Sam oh hell
yeah oh hell yeah oh hell yeah
okay so I'll be back with you guys
reading messages in just a bit if I die
I'm gonna read a few more messages in
between each time but we'll see how this
goes in just the immediate time all
right D 9 3 4 1 oh yeah that's what it
always is anyway so this intro sequence
shouldn't be any different than what it
originally was Oh
usually they let me in here forever the
day I die oh there we go okay do me a
favor all right I'll do you a favor by
the way oh yeah no yeah I like take your
gun and shoot you in the back I guess I
won't need to worry about that very soon
you're gonna get shot up as it is
oh god damn it
not my days bro the only reason I still
come here is for the pizza I don't know
what it is about that pizza but it's
delicious tuna casserole on the other
hand is a disgusting abomination and it
should be locked up in here with the
rest of these freaks
[Laughter]
well then alright okay follow all the
instructions okay thank you thank you
sir thank you for the lovely
introduction I'm glad that you're here
with me through this time forever and
ever
alright so anyway at least is working
all the memories god I'm like flooded
with memories right now I like I first
played this game so long ago before
these guys were even like fully modeled
or anything it may not have even like
like he used to start just right there
my contact with scp-173
well everything's gone all kinds bad
maybe we should get out of here
okay so in this mode oh hello
press f5 to save okay I did it
oh they're smart oh it's a tutorial oh
they're trying to teach me how to play
this oh I see how it's going but too bad
for them I already know how to play see
down there oh he's down there isn't it
oh man they made this a lot more creepy
than it used to be okay is it here yeah
okay okay didn't quite catch that
message there if you could repeat it for
me that'd be great oh shut the [ __ ] up
trying to concentrate
alrighty then
oh good I'm gonna keycard at least start
off the bat in this Cup
I'll need that cup actually it may not
seem like a whole lot right now but I am
gonna need that eventually the akyuu as
there is some sort of liquid dispenser I
don't know what it does fully but let's
see endothermic pak based predators
that's not good
highly permit a little moisture in
translucent oh I know what that is
that's the stuff in the basement if I'm
not mistaken is this a series of
hallways recursive spatial phenomenon
yeh I got it achievement okay they're
glad they have that yeah
oh boy okay all right then well that's a
thing I need to worry about that
okay all right then moving on moving on
okay what do you guys think shy go left
or right I've got a choice here I need a
I need a solid answer left or right left
right
I know it's probably gonna be split
right down the middle of left or right
but I just want to know what the balance
between people voting left and people
blowing right is yeah okay I'm getting a
lot of Inbetweeners okay I'm seeing
predominantly more left than I am right
okay now it's more right than it is left
okay I don't know which one you want so
I'm just gonna any meenie miney mo this
any meenie miney moe catch a tiger by
the toe baby y'all and let it go I'll go
left you guys seem to like left fine
[Music]
[ __ ] up concentrate killed that's right
I hear Oh
oh mama stop telling them to shut the
frak up cuz okay so so bill Bali
belieber Lally Oh how's it going that's
that's it bad who see I forgot about
that one Allen alrighty then are you
okay do you need medical assistance hey
then hey since you guys voted left last
time I'm gonna vote right this time
alrighty then
Oh key card is this good enough nah not
high enough clearance there's also some
low frame rate around oh yeah yeah you
can't scare me with easy skiers like
that I already know my [ __ ] around here
damn it I need higher security clearance
level 1 doesn't get you anywhere in this
game like it barely gets you into the
most low end of all things
alright I'm gonna go left this time oh
it's just eyes a checkpoint but I don't
think I don't think level 1 gets you
through this I'm pretty sure yeah you
need
you you are you uh you okay whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa something just pulled my
vision over there okay I don't know what
it was but I don't like it okay I don't
see anyone crying like a little baby
over there so I'm gonna go the other way
all right what do we got here goddamn it
stop doing that this is whipping my
vision around and I know for a fact
that's an SCP that's not just the mouse
being all janky like that that's an eye
that's a goddamn SCP okay oh no I'm not
going in that out now thank you no no
wait I have to go in that [ __ ] all right
here we go oh hi you're in there I know
you are oh god where is it where is it
where is it oh god I forgot about that
it's over there okay all right don't
kill me don't kill me don't kill me
don't kill me don't kill me don't kill
me don't kill me okay where are you aah
that's problem this is far enough hi
Karen E Ernie Ernie Ernie L forgot about
the hair never even oh boy that's bad oh
boy all right I forgot about that one
it's been so long since I played this
the checkpoint system is all wonky whoo
oh [ __ ] I don't want to go down in the
basement yet I don't think I have a
thing I need up here because I believe
oh no oh no oh no
what is that what's he getting black in
there Larry Larry don't do it Larry
Larry Larry why did I don't like that
okay [ __ ] you try my on this one oh boy
oh boy oh I can't save the game in this
one I can't save it until I use the key
card in the thing oh boy okay god damn
it's just another elevator oh there's a
dead guy in that one that's that's awful
I don't like that
man there's a lotta there's a lot of
there's a lot of a lot a lot of scaredy
babies in chatty right I didn't want to
call you straight-up cowards or nothing
but there's a lot of scaredy babies that
are just like every time there's
something I know how you be don't worry
I'm here to guide you through this
experience and start defending and
there's so many checkpoint whoa
I found the architect apparently hello
hi buddy how you doing there oh you're
weird okay alright then you have a good
one you have a good'n
yeah you have good now you have good and
take good take good and have it have
good - take it take good wherever you go
and have that just have it all why why
is it weirdly dark in here oh no what is
the owner memetic hazard one one two
three I don't know what one one two
three does oh it's not even a key card
is system picking button oh well I can't
stop spinning me I know you're doing
that on purpose
don't touch okay captain a hermetically
sealed container an argon gat asthma
sphere and not be tested during storage
temperature human skull missing the
lower mandible in all its T's growth for
it is modern Khmer script written in
blood that translates remember that will
report an anomalous sensory phenomena
including smells sounds tactile respond
when subjects return to touch the
surface they will experience a
dissociative fugue state confusing
disorientation adoption of a new
identity don't touch I want to touch it
oh I want to touch it can I save with
that I can okay save got it nice for
concise I got lost four times trying to
main it okay so I need your opinion
should I touch it should I touch it guys
should I should I touch it there's still
people that are saying run run run
nice it's a skull all right gas masks at
least maybe I can drop these things
gonna I don't need them anymore
yep don't need these just take them
space should I touch it should I should
I touch it can I even get in there oh no
I can't touch it I need a higher
clearance I want to touch it so badly I
bet there's a reason to touch it I bet
if it teaches you a language it doesn't
outright kill you like there's probably
a reason that you would have to touch
that thing right I mean it only makes
sense right
maybe I'm just gonna keep checking to
make sure that all these yeah I think I
think the lockdown is just not allowing
anyone to go through where am i what the
hell is Oh got it
turn me around again I thought I'd
changed the whole world on me okay all
right just the hallway oh I'm at an
elevator
god dammit another elevator I don't need
elevators I need oh it's the music ooh
the music's always fun oh come on level
one doesn't do jack [ __ ] um I think I'm
about to circle run
I hear you I hear you I hear you
scp-1162-j MIT I've got nothing oh I've
got so much nothing is he creeping
I saw moving Oh No
but I think if I go down there I might
actually get something important that's
is another level one isn't it
yeah I don't need a level one but I'll
keep it just in case I find the UH the
watch Emma who's it you know what I'm
talking about the the big machine that
transfers things into other machines and
I I can't remember but I got to go down
there I don't know what I picked up oh
[Music]
hey oh [ __ ] me
okay all right I gotta get around it and
up and close that door just gotta get up
around and close that I really open the
thing where it doesn't swing my vision
around doesn't happen when I'm near that
thing cuz that is instant death there's
a hundred percent death okay what did I
even get I got a clipboard god damn its
clipboard that can hold all the papers I
don't need the papers
[Music]
memory access violation great can't even
load let me try to get back in here let
me try to get back in I forgot how much
this game can spook ya the games is
boogie games real spooky alright let's
see if it's gonna load oh boy alright ok
alright ok looks like it loaded but I'm
back where I didn't want to be so I'm
gonna real quick I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna try to read some chat real quick
it's cuz I've been a little bit away
from that oh boy oh boy my whole my ol
uh my whole chrome crashed makes me
think that maybe the RAM in my computer
this is the same computer that I've been
using since um since I first came to LA
I think it might be time to upgrade my
computer pretty soon but until then I'm
desperately not gonna hold on to that
I'm gonna I'm gonna desperately cling on
to ever this computer for as long as I
can and if I can I'm gonna be very happy
about that but we're gonna get back into
it let me just get back here
that's no good
ah alright oh boy okay so I might try
again here we go here we go and flappity
bloobity blip BLAP where am I
where are you there we go okay all right
if I'm correct max Levine says the Larry
seed would make a CP 106 activist all
[ __ ] let's see
Jessica Kat Nick says aw Marky who died
worst chica chica is not in here right
now chicas laying in a bed man the spy
says it's so nice to see you get back
into sp it's the reason I subbed
originally back when you had 7000
subscribers thank you so much grace
Caroline says mark I wanted to tell you
that your determination inspired me to
apply for uni got in I'll be starting my
BA psych next year love you lots well
good lucky you in university so thank
you so much all right
Giavanna malone says I'm so sick but I'm
glad I am home to watch you you always
make me feel better and I'm so lucky to
have you in my life I gave you a letter
at PAX East this year if you find it
please let me know I've got a few boxes
of pack C stuff over in my living room I
now I mean to do a video that very soon
and I'll try to get back to that as soon
as I can but it takes a lot to get to so
oh yes dark shadow says SP Larry's
coming for you seriously though great to
see you back in SC p well thank you so
much I'm glad to be here too some a
Russian name I can't pronounce this hi
I'm from Russia I have a question are
you the trace legacy character prototype
and who is flora prototype then I have
no idea I have no idea
oh are you talking about my brothers
comment cuz he has characters named tres
and flora I'm assuming you mean like the
inspiration for those characters no I'm
not I don't think I'm any inspiration
for that and I honestly don't know you'd
have to ask my brother on that one about
his comic my brother writes the comic
two kinds for those of you who have read
that or heard of it before uh it's a
it's a pretty popular web comic he's
been doing it for like thirteen fourteen
years now so I'm pretty proud of my
brother and what he's done so if you've
ever if you ever in the web comics or
stuff like that check those up
two kinds dotnet two spelled out now
like the number well I mean it is the
number but it's the number two spelled
out t wo kinds dotnet I think it is
anyway so back into this we got to get
back so if I recall I'm gonna go over
here
that's nothing this is a hallway and
then at the end of this is an elevator
and then I'm back where I need to be
yeah okay so oh [ __ ] got stopped doing
that it's doing that on purpose it's not
me which I knew why
[Music]
ok there dad
I don't need to go back down there I
don't need to know about 173 but I guess
I will get a clipboard eventually don't
need that get the batteries okay I'm
gonna go down there I'll get the
batteries it's gonna be super cool and
chill and awesome and where the hell is
he I don't know which side he's on
okay I see oh no you know yeah okay all
right then
don't even [ __ ] try me bro all right
I'm out I'm out I'm out of yeah I'm out
of yeah I don't have a lot of time I'm
outtie oh I'm outie okay this time don't
[ __ ] open that goddamn door where's
the goddamn door thing okay okay yeah hi
worked okay well these are okay I don't
know what that is you're like oh that's
the ear thing I know about the ear thing
do your thing is weird okay I'm gonna
close this bad boy all right where am I
I have no idea
oh how the [ __ ] did you get there babe
[ __ ] god damn it oh god oh god oh god
oh god okay all right I need to get back
in there there's a level two key card in
there [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I have to draw
him out somehow [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay
nice bus still there yep be still there
oh I can't get around him I got a good
mat here okay
[ __ ] okay all [ __ ] on me did the thing
it did the thing where you look it's
okay buddy you're all right you're all
right you're all right it's okay I can't
save at any time I want you guys to know
this in this particular game-mode
they've updated it so there's a
difficulty where you can only save at
computer terminals you know what I'm
just gonna forget
I might just [ __ ] forget about
getting the goddamn clipboard because
honestly who needs the clipboard the
clipboard is not important the clipboard
is just not bit
ah he's not here right now he's not here
right now mrs. Torrance okay
so we're good there lock that up wait ah
level two key card now we don't need the
level one anymore but I'm gonna hold on
to it just in case but I've also got
this the Navigator and this has
batteries in it so this shows me where
I've been and where I need to go oh [ __ ]
another airlock don't [ __ ] with me don't
stop do that
stop stop do that stop do that stop do
that god [ __ ] I hate that it's so
goddamn much dammit
higher clearance damn at level two is
still not enough Oh No
can I run through this okay I can
that's a Tesla gate that's one of the
ways to stop radical Larry if radical
Larry goes through that when it's active
it'll zap them dead
I need a console to save [ __ ] okay so I
haven't gone south goes nowhere
apparently we just see where that goes
okay the South goes nowhere I have not
gone this way ah easy
each nine one four oh dude okay please
tell me this is enough yes okay so I'm
in here oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[Music]
okay [ __ ] okay so I need to remember dr.
L I don't know why I'm bothering I'm the
only one alive anymore I think or maybe
just sane or am i even that much at this
point I feel like I have to leave
something behind some char to myself
I've seen the others I know I'll most
likely not even leave today a body so
maybe that's what this is shivering
myself off slithering myself off leaving
bread crumbs on my brain scattered and
tattered I keep learning things in the
dark it's almost worse than what's in
the light I taste metal what the [ __ ]
does that mean yeah so anyway this
machine is the refinery it um it
basically will refine pretty much
anything you have in various different
ways
as a reminder Norg no organic matters to
be entered into scp-1946 to him put both
checklist we do not wish a repeat of the
spider steel wire incident last week
okay so if you guys remember
if you guys remember there is some way
to get the key card to get better now I
can't remember the exact way to do that
but there is a way to do it and I need
you guys to tell me exactly how to do
that so if you guys I'm looking at chat
right now
and I hope you guys have an answer for
me so I'm just gonna read some things
sofa King says what is this 2014 all
jokes aside though it's great to see you
playing an old fan favorite never forget
mark that you've got people everywhere
who will support you even people in the
military like me I look forward to
seeing you play this game again in
another three years
oh that's very optimistic about my
channel but thank you so much in three
years
it'll be the year 2020 so honestly who
knows what's gonna happen in 2020 novus
says hey mark my name is Novus and I'm a
small youtuber trying to reach a hundred
subs I wonder if you're able to help me
reach my goal well just said your name
so hopefully that helps blue Spartan
gaming says I would love it if you play
inspire a markiplier fan game on your
channel it's game I put a lot of effort
into and I've started working on a
sequel it would be an achievement for me
to see you play it I do want to play
more markiplier fan games and in fact I
like the format of doing like a live
stream like this for that so I hope that
someday I'll be able to do that in terms
of just like doing a live stream with
you guys and then you know just just
being able to do that and see you guys
and talk to you guys about it and you
know it could be it could be just a lot
of fun and I really do appreciate that
matthäus
professor barb otto barbados says hi
mark I'm Brazilian history teacher and
podcaster I follow you for about four
years now and I love your work you
helped me pass through some bad moments
in my life thank you Anthony Earl says
lovely Marquis boo Molly says oh wait no
I actually read that one I believe Molly
it's another personal story is just
thanking me for helping her through a
very tough time in her life and I hope
you're doing okay Molly I really hope
you are Jessica Steiner says you're an
amazing person Marc you have a huge
heart and a beautiful soul thank you for
everything you're doing for us yes I
will be playing out less - okay try the
level one key card on the one to one
setting of first
j-jake Kim says while my future husband
is really cool no but thanks for the
constant mood lifting with your videos
MIDI the wolf says third and last time
I'm posting this but coming from
crippling bedridden for four years I can
say that you save lives you saved mine
anyways thanks I really do appreciate
that I'm glad that I was able to help
you through those times like I can't
imagine what it's like to be bedridden
for four years let alone some people
that are watching that have been
bedridden for their entire life and
that's that's that's a horrible thing to
go through and I'm glad that my videos
can help in some way
so anyway I've got the advice of going
uh going from one to one and then oh
show met said mark get a better card you
[ __ ] and go touch that skull
so I'm gonna go do that but after I did
this so someone said take the level one
and put it on one two one fine
unfortunately I can't save right now
whoa hey buddy okay don't don't dick I
think it's level one and then one to one
that's what they said level one one to
one I remember it used to be fine but
they said one to one so I'm on trust
them
and they they definitely improve the
sound effects on this one that is a
playing card that does not help me in
any capacity that didn't work at all and
let me try it again
one-to-one Kerch uncle's stick the card
up your butt do you really think that's
a good option for me sticking the card
up my butt what is that gonna do for me
okay so I made it back into a key a
level one key card so let me try fine
I'll try fine let's see that I remember
that used to work
hmm we thought Frick was that all right
no that just turned it into a MasterCard
which didn't do me any good okay let's
see if I can get it back into working
order
let's see level 2 card on fine and then
someone said level 2 card on very fine
and I'm like hey I don't want to risk my
card like that cuz I can't save well I
got another level 2 key card so hey I
guess alright you know what I'm gonna
put a level 2 on I'll put up a level 2
one very fine chip let's see if this
works they don't know
it's a MasterCard again okay so I'm
gonna try this what if I put the master
garden here and then very fine again and
then shoot it's a level two again okay
so so I've got a level two so the only
thing whoa okay the only thing I haven't
tried is level two on fine I mean they
may have removed this ability for this
to be improved like this I'm gonna put
the Navigator in there soon because I do
want the deluxe ooh whoo that is a level
three card I got it okay I'll take a
level three I'm gonna put the Navigator
in there and put that on fine I think
extra fine we'll just break it
cameras blurry what do you mean cameras
blurry what does that even mean okay I
think this is the super Navigator now ah
yes the super navigator with all the
maps already done okay try rough I'm not
gonna do that but the s nav on very fine
I thought the S nav on just fine was
good enough
[Music]
you guys are leading me astray I don't
know about that but I've got a level
three card I think that's gonna be good
enough are you know I'm a touch the sky
I'm a touch the skull I'm I just I'm
gonna go touch the skull cuz then I can
save and come back because I got a level
three and a better navigator and I think
that's gonna be good enough so I'm gonna
go touch a skull and probably die
horrible death Tanner tanner tanner
tanner tanner tanner
good thing I left all these doors open
that's definitely gonna help me in the
long run
Tanner [ __ ] was that whoa what is this
what is this what is this what is this
what is this what are you I stop that
stop that well there's a plane card but
I don't need that
it's another navigator but I guess I
guess of a [ __ ] Saab that
Oh radical Larry hi hi hi okay alright
that's bad I don't know how to stop you
just yet I needed to go touch the skull
and you're chasing me now [ __ ] shitty
tits oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
okay yep that's that's bad time okay
Oh No
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
no
well [ __ ] open and close okay right
this bad oh where the [ __ ] am i I didn't
mean to come in here this is not where I
meant to go [ __ ] [ __ ] ah dicks ah poopy
[Music]
right oh [ __ ] I'm just waiting for that
yeah
hi yeah a decayed March yeah that's no
good where are you
[ __ ] you're in front yucky he's faster
than he's faster than a you City by a
good margin okay
blink Blanc don't be caught damn don't
get oh god damn it you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] just [ __ ] you yeah yeah ring
around the [ __ ] rosey [ __ ] han or
yourself end up [ __ ] death ya piece
of [ __ ] I gotta get to the goddamn safe
point cuz [ __ ] it was that the skull is
this going here I forget [ __ ] [ __ ] what
is that I don't know where that goes out
I'll be right back for that I just need
a goddamn [ __ ] stop spinning me I just
need a goddamn thing
scp-500 scp-1498 Boop okay alright
okay we're doing okay we're doing all
right
some ones we can get through this okay
what are these things I don't know what
this is higher clearance good enough
clearance what are you that looks that
looks bad that looks bad that looks like
something I shouldn't take that looks
like something I definitely shouldn't
take I'm gonna read up on it first okay
gas mask seal anomalous effects one
second subject vanishes from view is no
longer detectable subject reports no
feeling of motion two-way radios what
what whoa weird the [ __ ] is that I'm
gonna put it on listen let's let's put
it on
okay oh hi oh hi Hidy Hidy Hidy oh oh oh
oh oh where am i oh oh the [ __ ] is that
were you humping your way down the road
humping my way downtown looking fast
okay that's weird I guess I'll go
towards them what are you gonna do kill
me well there's a lot of them panner
Hannah Hannah Hannah Hannah Hannah
Hannah Hannah Hannah Hannah hello hi
hello hi hello where are you going what
are you doing
hello you run in from me what are you
unlike this
[Music]
uh-oh you're weird
nice oh hey hey hey hey hey oh god
they're all after me Oh God
I'm taking it off ow
I seem to be bleeding profusely gonna
put on this first-aid kit because holy
[ __ ] your wounds are way too severe to
staunch the bleeding complete oh I'm
gonna die
oh is that what you're saying I'm gonna
I'm gonna die I'm just limping along
baby it was a bad idea
well better finish it off a guess a
where am I now what the [ __ ] is that
odds is an empty spot what the [ __ ] well
I'm gonna die that's long in the short
of that one I am a dead man whoo
the corner of your eye what the [ __ ] you
talking about stop stop the corner of my
eye oh no oh no oh no I'm real short now
odo odo odo I'm losing a lot of blood
odo odo I'm gonna die thou old oh oh no
oh no oh no I'm gonna die oh go odo
oh it hurts a lot just watch you go log
odo let's see what's up here anyway
since I'm gonna die no matter what
sprint Brent run run I can't even like I
can't walk up stairs well [ __ ]
odo oh [ __ ] Oh doh Oh
looks like I owe that is that my blood
oh it's hard to look at where help I'm
just gonna stay here and embrace the
sweet suede suede embrace a death yeah
I'm dying yeah I'm dying it so uh you're
feeling faint from the amount of blood
you lost without a radical area behind
me there's that a sepm why would you do
that you're sure
ouch dude Oh can't see [ __ ] here Larry
belly I don't want to just end my misery
please
I was gonna load the cave I'm gonna load
the game because that was taking way too
long okay so now then I'm not dying I'm
gonna go back here on my investigate oh
look my blood is still there who would
have thought now i'm gonna investigate
what's up here ooh this looks important
this looks very important oh stop that
stop it okay this looks like the power
control room that the computer SCP
wanted me to turn on but it is slightly
do wait I'm in there wait no wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait oh [ __ ]
wait wait wait wait hi hi
no I'd rather not no no no no no no no
no no no no no nono nono nono nono nono
nono nono nono nono nono nono nono nono
nono nono nono nono nono nono nono no no
lock it lock it lock it lock it no no no
no ahh [ __ ] [ __ ] that's too bad I don't
want the disease abhi I like the disease
well that didn't go good for me was it
good for you [ __ ] ok we are in trouble
[Music]
so I need to get by that doctor to be
able to go up into that control room
because I bet that's a control room to
release the lockdown
stop doing that achievement the corner
of your eye achievement I don't like
that achievement I don't like that
achievement so he's there how do I get
by him do I go go the long way around
thank God
all righty then let's do that one fudge
Wow who's got big honking footsteps oh
boy stop that okay so where am I going I
need to go all the way back around to
the other side I need to make it back to
that machine again because I'm pretty
sure there's got to be a way that I can
make a higher level of this card I just
have to find it okay I need to stop
being a little baby about this so I know
those go nowhere because according to
this map they just go no what ooh it's
the skull oh I'm gonna touch it hey I
gotta say first
save put this away I'm gonna touch it
I'm gonna touch that sumbitch I'm gonna
touch it yeah touch it
oh yeah
[Music]
just [ __ ] oh hi oh my god are you a Nazi
okay okay
alrighty then
yeah holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] oh god this
isn't the same oh no where am I oh where
am I where am I
oh hi hello okay well I'm back to the
death walk I'm gonna die odo odo odo
dancy's clay Big B okay
I can't see anything
oh hi okay alright then ah I'm dead and
I'm not dead what what da [ __ ] that's so
weird
what those so weird I can only imagine
that was like a skull from someone from
the concentration camps of world war ii
during the holocaust that's what that
seemed like that was what the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] was that what that was I don't know
I don't know oh my god i'ma save cuz
seems like I'm okay that's so messed up
it's so messed up oh man okay carrying
on carrying on
Oh touch it again touch it again alright
fine I'm gonna touch it again but if
it's the same thing I'm I'll be very
pissed all right I'm gonna touch it I
can't carry any more items yeah it won't
let me touch it again I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna touch it again I think I
learned my lesson the first time around
cuz holy [ __ ] okay so I'm gonna make my
way back to the all the way around to
the Machine again and I'm gonna try to
get a higher level card because that's
what I need right now I could go in
there I don't know if there's gonna be
any benefit to going in there other than
the music that makes me want to write it
and kill myself
[ __ ] stop that back
oh oh oh I can't just doing it
automatically
grabbity Beppo do you guys know about
this one can't help it god oh right
oh boy here we go ow
I have to laughter
I can do this
choice
[Music]
yes yes yes bad yeah it's bad
yeah it's bad
yeah it's pretty bad it's bad yeah it's
bad it's bad yeah oh
oh I think I died so long well yeah
that's the lesson about that one yeah I
only wrote three lines that's wall I did
that's all I did
Oh member no no febri access violation
Dao Dao Dao I'm going back in I'm going
back in yeah why did I do that a lot of
people like would you do that I was like
yeah just to show you guys what was
going on hey guys another funky way to
die
oh also someone said someone said to get
the the mask that took you to the other
world and bring it to the Machine and
that's actually a really good idea I'm
gonna go back and try to get that
because I think that's just before the
excuse me the plague doctors there so if
I can get that from like before the
plague doctor actually is there then
hopefully I will be able to grab that
and take it with me all the way around
I'll just have to backtrack a little bit
but it's important because if that is
something that can be put in the Machine
and turned into something really cool
then I want to know what that is so I'm
gonna find that I'm gonna do that as
crazy as it is down there in crazy land
blue ink okay so I'm gonna go back and
I'm gonna find that hope nothing kills
me on the way
Hannah Hannah Hannah Hannah Hannah okay
so I obviously can't take the skull with
me so I can't put that in the machine at
all but you can definitely take that
mask which I think was just over the
rainbow here just around the Riverbend
got it couldn't have been that far away
maybe the plague doctor is gone by now
and then I can go back the other way and
hopefully that's gonna be a little easy
[ __ ] I forgot about that okay
everything's fine everything's fine
good good good good good so far so good
I always get so anxious when I walked
through these halls cuz I'm like at any
moment you could have either Larry or
Billie pop up out of nowhere and just
[ __ ] your day up I think he's here also
here yeah I was here okay what's that
what is that
Emily Ross who the hell is Emily Ross so
it's a level 2 keycard but well I mean I
don't need it I guess
save okay okay
maybe Emily Ross could open this one no
I can't even do it it's just an ID card
okay I'm gonna take this with me I'm not
gonna put it on but I'm gonna take it
with me then I'm gonna go it sounds like
there's a plague doctor right here No
all right okay all right then okay he
seems to be gone okay I believe that
[ __ ] [ __ ] god damn it no
oh [ __ ] this bad well shitty tits off I
can't even turn off the heavy
containment zone but at least I got that
off all right Larry where yet Oh Larry
Oh Larry Oh Larry Oh Larry oh you're not
just walking through [ __ ] this time papa
light of you and weird and out of
character and I don't like that yi yi
okay all right go go go go go go go go
no time to waste
we gotta go we gotta go we gotta go we
gotta go we gotta go
is this it
no this was not it this is Zen not it
but what is this
oh yeah that's that weird room that led
nowhere and goddamnit I'm wasting time
here okay I think he stopped loves those
Larry stopping was that stopping I think
he stopped not ever since you were okay
wasn't there was it oh this was it this
is it this is it is it okay
so alright so we got a lot of [ __ ] but I
need your opinion on this one I need to
know this is my inventory right now I
have a gas mask that is an SCP I have a
plain car to have an Emily Ross badge I
have a navigator I have a normal gas
mask and a cup and two key cards so I
need to turn these things into better
version these things so in the comments
right what I need to do make sense
I'll also read some other comments that
have been coming behind since I last
read them so JJ Kim oh I've already read
that one so krojack says I saw your
video Pursuit of Happyness two years ago
and it inspired me like you could never
understand now I'm at 120 thousand
subscribers and living my dream this is
all thanks to you well thank you so much
and I'm glad that you were able to
pursue your dream Brown AIDS brown-eyed
psycho said hey Marc I'm glad you're
playing the game that got me watching
your channel in the first place thank
you so much for helping through my
depression thank you for taking a photo
of my fan game at PAX it meant a lot to
me that you cared enough to do that as
long as you're here we'll be here too
and yes I do want to play more of those
fan games I do intend to I want to do a
livestream where I just play a whole
bunch of them see Chris Berlin said oh
my god I never thought I'd see more SCP
containment breach mark I love you well
thank you so much uh and then Nicolas
Lewis says can you please say hi to me
and my friends Sarah garlic also where
have you decided to go on tour we
haven't decided the exact cities yet but
King we're thinking vaguely in now I
can't even say III really can't say
because I'd just be spoiling and enter
ruining possibilities of doing these
things so I want to do I want to be I
want to tell you guys everything then we
will be telling you guys everything very
soon but just a little bit longer it
will know exactly what okay gas mask
plus fine equals a liniment stamina okay
I believe you there see gas mask on fine
so I'm gonna do that for someone who put
the gas mask on fine there's other
things to do besides that though I know
that for sure I know the SCP thing can
probably be done as well shunk okay
the weird gas masks on ultra-fine are
very fun you said ultra fine so I'm I
think you maybe not know you can breathe
easier
okay it's not unlimited stamina oh it is
unlimited stamina that's right that's
weird
yeah good stuff good stuff
stop skittering you bastard okay battery
on very fine wait hang on maybe I'm not
reading this right hang on level 3 2
extra fine put the ID on very fine okay
I'll put the ID on very fine because
that's not losing me anything but I'm
gonna try that
iíd on very fine
whoa that was a big twist okay okay what
do we got here
to do or didn't do anything what why
would it why didn't it do anything to it
there's a QR code on this I don't know
what that would lead to wait hang on let
me scan this QR code on my my phone here
cuz I'm curious steal all my stuff but
I'm gonna scan this QR code because that
is it's peculiar
yeah just literally that's just the data
of the card but it does show a code here
there is a code why is there a code here
it's a code there's a code here that
says five 5.6 seven eight seven four 1-4
0.065 seven eight four so are those
coordinates once again I'm gonna read
this the code says it's fifty five dot
six seven eight seven four one - 4.0 six
five seven eight four
so whatever that code means it might be
latitude and longitude coordinates or it
might be a code to something else or
maybe you're supposed to subtract it
because it might be a subtraction symbol
instead of just a dash but that's
something I don't know what that is but
that is something so maybe you guys can
figure that out
okay okay level two key card on fine for
level three what do I do for the level
three key card
[Music]
you guys are saying level three key card
on very fine so I'm gonna trust you on
that one
I did save so if this screws it up then
it's your fault that little thing is
skittering in there with me - Master
Card a [ __ ] all right Eve Adam we're
gonna try this this way put this back
flap level three on fine
hey you were saying very fine I'm
getting mixed messages here super fun
other things super fun is it oh god damn
it downgraded it to level two so level
two on fine created them level two on
fine created the level three right
that's what it did I believe in so what
happens if you put level three on fine
that would probably maybe get it up to
level four I don't know oh it's a master
card again god damn it oh boy this is
gonna be a [ __ ] isn't it
nope level two again
god damnit level two on very fine
is that it
[Music]
level three on one two one that might be
it
that might be it that might be it okay
someone said playing card on very fine
playing card on very fine and then level
three on one to one that would make more
sense oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] why here why now
oh no oh no oh no I gotta go I gotta go
I gotta leave [ __ ] but I gotta get what
was in there
[ __ ] okay I'm on tried dodgem [ __ ] you
ah [ __ ]
I grabbed it grabbed it level - [ __ ] now
what I wanted
I got a pawn on the gas mask okay hope
let's go ship okay we're gonna ship out
of here treble - ever - ever - ebony I'm
so fast cher - ever - ever - ever - ever
- ever - ebony she ever - ever - ever -
ever you okay you still follow me okay
so I have to level twos in a MasterCard
now not exactly what I wanted but it's
what I got I need to get back there I
gotta get back there there's way to get
a level four card but I just haven't
been able to do it still there
oh he is there okay I just got to get
far enough away man I am so fast
I'm ludicrously fast okay save okay
sounds like he's gone okay I'm gonna go
back there good good good good
I am so fast [ __ ] dude
okay so I'm gonna get this this off okay
I'm gonna do a little goof I'm gonna put
the SCP gas mask in there and I'm gonna
put that on very fun see what happens if
that works great if it doesn't [ __ ]
whoa whoa whoa what the [ __ ] [ __ ] you
okay ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow I'm
dead okay
well [ __ ] me then okay an ident
unidentified male and a deceased Class D
subject were discovered in blank by nine
tailed fox the man was described as
highly agitated and seemed to only speak
Russian he's been taken into a temporary
holding area at redacted while waiting
for a translator to arrive what weird
weird weird okay weird whoa that was
super weird I have no idea what's going
on with that that was so weird
that was so weird you guys knew that was
gonna have an engine you guys knew some
of you anyway a lot of you might have
been oh yeah a lot of you are just a
surprise design but some of you guys
know your new O is gonna happen I see
your game okay I gotcha
okay I see okay so let's not do that
again and let's try to get this into a
some sort of a level three I gotta get a
level three here because I need at least
the level three again to try to do the
one two one
because if I can do that then I'm better
off that's a level two god I've got so
many level twos now let me try a level
two on one two one
that's a playing card again
let me try playing card on one two one
medkit on very funny I'm gonna do that I
know that's gonna be either bad or very
good I can't remember which is which Wow
Jesus has just made a level one keycard
[ __ ] level one on very fine did nothing
right because I can't progress anywhere
unless I get these but I did open up the
containment areas so I can go to the
containment areas but I do need a higher
level control what is that oh my god
it's the Omni card it's the [ __ ] Omni
card the Omni card can unlock anything
oh [ __ ] dude oh [ __ ] ah [ __ ] dude okay
so that's good I'm gonna I'm gonna wait
is this a trap is this a trap first aid
on very fine is that a trap I think that
kills me doesn't it that kills me
doesn't it that kills me doesn't it that
kills me doesn't it that kills me I know
this is good but that kills me doesn't
it now that kill that kills me I know
that's a trap that's a trap you guys are
tricking me that kills me yeah you guys
are tricking me you guys a tricky beat
you guys are tricking me yeah yeah okay
all right so I got the ultimate
navigator and the gas mask that allows
me to run indefinitely
so I just gotta get to a save point
before I die so I'm gonna try to run
down do the same one that I went to
before straight down this hallway link
Blanc
nothing big deal about it no big deal no
big steez no big steez there's no C's
about this I'm not having a STIs here
you guys Steven I'm not Steven yeah just
like that lamp saved got it nailed
locked in blam
okay oh okay alright so now that we got
this and the ultimate navigator scp-049
is right on top of me
is that the bug
I think that's the bug yeah it's the bug
it's oh okay it's the bug it's somewhere
okay oh oh nine six is here where is oh
nine six I'm gonna take off the gas mask
because I can't see with it on what why
is everything get dark when I look at
that it's such [ __ ] you know that
it's [ __ ] okay
wait there was another thing in here I
see p500 whatever that was okay
I see p500 is in here what is that it's
not here wait SCP 500 miles east ORD in
a cool dry place level 4 small plastic
can one pill effectively cures the
diseases the subject of all diseases in
200 this is the pill oh okay
get AIDS and then ask permission oh wow
so it's not here though so someone must
have taken scp-500 I see okay so someone
took scp-500 in the hopes of curing
something and then Oh 96 is here wait oh
nine six oh nine six isn't oh nine six
is
[Music]
Oh nine six isn't Billy Oh nine six
isn't that mr. long arms isn't that mr.
grabby hands isn't that mr. don't look
at my face why why why is oh nine six
here that that that that's that's not
right that's not right
oh my god I'm getting closer to it oh my
god oh nine six is on the other side of
this door oh no oh no oh no that crime
the crime the crying wasn't a person the
crying was oh nine six
[Music]
oh [ __ ] and I'm brave don't look don't
look don't look don't look don't look at
me I'm not looking not looking
oh hey Jay Jay Jay Jay I don't know how
to not look at you oh no oh no wait whoa
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that
and [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] off with you oh okay
this bad I'm a guy before radical Larry
gets me all right this way then I guess
[ __ ] Larry being a piece of [ __ ] and
that lady's just got zapped to hell okay
where am i where am i where am i where
am i where am i well that's bad that's a
bad sound what is this I don't want to
go in there that's radical Larry's
closing no that's the oh [ __ ] what is
that
[ __ ] off [ __ ] off vodka
oh [ __ ] all what are you the cowbell
goddamnit Bing bong ding dong Bing bong
bring it on god I don't need any of that
I don't need that right now I don't need
that Bing bong bring it off [ __ ]
where's the goddamn computer terminal I
need to save like right now oh ok that I
need to close to open the door oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] where am
i where am i goddammit here go go go go
go go rubber duckie rubber duckie I hate
you
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] nuts s
nobody knows life
goddamnit memory access violation oh
[ __ ] I'm getting back in I'm not
stopping yet now I gotta stop I'm not
gonna stay up [ __ ] I'm not gonna stop
him going back in go back in oh boy that
did not go well for me that did not go
well for me that did that went the
opposite of good yeah I got bone there I
got bones I got boned real hard there
was some serious boning happen to me and
I did not like it yeah black okay didn't
mag into it
getting back into it where am I
I have all my things I'm okay I don't
know how the [ __ ] I'm gonna get past oh
nine six again but holy hell here we go
I know there are other entrances I do
both the gas mask and the Navigator and
then see absolutely nothing I can't see
[ __ ]
there's a door in front of me and I
can't [ __ ] open it
oh that's cuz I'm at the thing I'm gonna
go this way I'm gonna go left this way
I'm gonna go through the other entrance
173 is around here okay taking this off
this back on blink long one seven three
give one seven three is nearby but very
far away so that's okay I just say oh
nine six is still there that's not
normal
oh nine six is still there why okay good
he's gone [ __ ] okay so if I go through
here I shouldn't have to worry about it
as much
okay good good good good okay so
hi okay alright that's bad that's bad
that's bad that's bad huh [ __ ] you never
getting me a goddamn break guys [ __ ] you
guys [ __ ] all you [ __ ] all you to hell
and die [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] YLF [ __ ]
right off where am I
not here FLAC go this way one seven six
there's no way to cross this branch now
[ __ ] I don't know what the what am I
looking at you guys got em containment
area
it's the architect by I don't think I
can go through here can I I can
apparently the [ __ ] I didn't think this
was a thing with this keep out of here
oh I don't have an access code no cuz
this thing it says on my map that it's
walled off anyway so I don't think
that's correct there's gotta be
something else here [ __ ]
okay I gotta go like it's gotta wait
until I see pee until radical air stops
chasing me and then I got to go around
him we're fine we're fine we're fine
let's go let's go for it let's go for it
let's go for it let's go for it let's go
for it let's go for it let's go no
that's not it
here we go this is what I'm looking for
cuz I'm gonna take this off so I can see
he's not gonna be here good good good
good okay there's a cowbell okay I'm on
the other side of that that's good to
know
all right so 173 is nearby I'm assuming
that he's gonna be in the same place
that he was don't do that
we read this in God in heaven hell I
think the wall cracked or the floor
ceiling I haven't been in up top in 12
years I don't know which edges top 12
years when the lock dropped the security
walls released each subsection is sealed
now we're all cut off 12 years what I
mean bulge like a bedsheet with a
naughty child underneath with a [ __ ]
talking about then just go back down my
teeth are feeling odd what okay bye
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ]
I'm stomach keep going if it load nope
it won't load I'm gonna keep going
anyway
[ __ ] I'm going again we're still doing
this we're not giving up on this
[ __ ] I'm not giving up on this god
damn it that really scared the piss out
of me that was like cuz I looked I
blinked it was fine and then I died like
what the [ __ ] happened I don't even know
where it came from I don't know what the
[ __ ] was going on I was at a complete
loss so I'm I do I'm gonna risk it with
uh I'm gonna risk it with Oh nine six
again am I going the right way no I am
not this on the [ __ ] was that the [ __ ]
was that the [ __ ] was that
okay either way I'm gonna risk it with
Oh nine six again it's gonna look at the
ground beneath the ground
I am looking at the ground I'm looking
at the ground look at the other odd
looking at the ground looking at the
ground look at the looking at the
[ __ ] ground looking at the [ __ ]
ground
that [ __ ] let's go back go go go dude
go hey go go alright then okay I'll go
thanks dude okay all right bye then
so radical areas gonna come anytime now
this lady's gonna get zapped over there
so there's no way to go there I have to
go this way okay all right we'll find
you thinks fine I mean everything is god
[ __ ] awful but Oh what is why is why
is that so shimmery I don't like to look
at that that's not good I'm gonna open
up this and maybe there's a safe point
in here oh please tell me there's a safe
way yes yes save save oh don't look at
that wait no that's not save point no I
don't need to turn that off stop looking
at it okay is there a safe point down
here
I don't think so
I don't think so I don't think so i
don't think so i don't think so i don't
think so i don't think so i don't think
so i don't think so i don't think so i
don't think so i don't think so this is
a point awful
[Music]
[ __ ] I don't think you guys know but I'm
like I'm not okay right now [ __ ] I can
only do so much horror at once [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay cowbell room [ __ ] the cowbell
no that's not the cowbell small teddy
bear can start oh yeah that's the thing
that makes the ear version of itself or
the okay all right
[Music]
okay there's Larry he's right there
that's fine cuz if I go this way Blanc
Blanc where are you buddy
where are you friend oh you round here
alright you're not okay oh no no I'm not
going in the goddamn elevator okay I
guess I'm just gonna go this way cuz I
got nothing better to do with my life
can where are you which side are you on
which side are you on which side are you
on which side are you want okay all
right
don't [ __ ] with me okay do not if you're
down here don't [ __ ] with me oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay all right don't just stop it
sticking with me it's sticking with me
do an extreme degree right now I'm Scapa
come back to that later later oh god
he's going through the floor is it me
it's going through the walls going
through the walls going through the
walls okay it's fine it's fine it's fine
okay he's done I need a save point 106
is nearby but that's okay that's Larry
when 7 3 is not nearby ok good good good
good
who is this is that that that's the
heavy containment zone isn't it but I
think it's locked down hey how's it
going again can you let me in okay no
all right then so that's a heavy
containment zone I don't need to go
there yet
probably all of these are heavy
containment zone entrances okay
ah here we go this is probably has one
if I remember this is a very weird one
okay this is a weird one the I this is
weird
yeah yeah yeah okay cuz it wants to be
on somebody high has gone I want to do
that
what man my vision is flippin more and
more these days I don't want to do that
I don't want to do that there's also an
access panel back here but I don't have
the code for it yeah yeah okay no I
don't think I might do that
yeah I don't trust him I don't trust him
I don't just and I'm gonna open the door
[Music]
there's nothing in here excuse me
there's nothing in here there was
nothing in there dude dude there was
nothing in there there's nothing in here
dude there's a whole lot of dick dude
this dick in there I don't trust you
[Music]
guess what they do you freaks tonight yo
I'm not gonna do it I'm gonna hold off
for a rainy day I need to say before I
do that okay whatever you have anyone
nearby and no we're good we're in the
clear so far
what is this why are you in there now
how did you get in there I'm not gonna
go in there no I'm not stop turning me
around goddamn it no
[Music]
yeah I'm not gonna go in there I can't
see [ __ ] though I'm not gonna go in
there yeah I'm not gonna go in there I
need to find a computer terminal again
that was the entrance to that thing
there's something over here whoa what is
this what happened what happened where
am I
where what is this I don't know this one
oh this is radical Larry's containment
area oh oh maybe I can maybe I can
hello again maybe I can walk him down
stop god it wants to spin me so much now
maybe I could lock him down give me a
goddamn save terminal please you feel
like something is here with me I you
don't see anything yeah I don't like
that I don't like that at all
[Music]
flocking oh hey buddy don't spin me for
God's sake don't spin me not now not now
okay [ __ ] don't do it don't do it okay
where am I
okay I need to go farther to the right I
need to find a goddamn computer terminal
[ __ ] everything's locked down
why is everything locked down can I open
this [ __ ] it's a four prong er so that's
nice
okay fair bagging
look okay so this is definitely locked
down yeah nothing okay
there's another SCP over here that's not
what I wanted
wait no that wasn't radical Larry that's
radical Larry where the [ __ ] is radical
Larry's thing I didn't want to come in
here yet [ __ ] what is that over there
nothing [ __ ] I gotta find god damnit
Larry you sack of [ __ ] stop it stop
being such an [ __ ] I just need a cup
you tower please come on just one please
one sweet delicious screen to save a
pond to thrust my data upon is a five
access card not like I need that
oh is this no it's not it's not is it
it's not it's not it's no I [ __ ] you -
[ __ ] this [ __ ] where is he coming
from okay he's coming from over there
[ __ ] him [ __ ] all that
okay so that didn't work out for me he's
done though where am I please what is
that
I've never seen this before where am I I
don't know where this is well I can't go
forward what the [ __ ] it's like some
invisible wall here [ __ ] what that makes
no sense
I don't know what's going on guys I have
no idea I'm so confused
god damnit [ __ ] elevator oh [ __ ] no
DNA god dammit okay I just need a
goddamn computer terminal I haven't
saved in ages I need something here give
goddamnit whatever that's right Bell a
[ __ ] Billy
he's behind me which is good
I see what looking down at the ground is
really cool to do yeah
where am I not here oh [ __ ] not here
[ __ ]
not here not here go go go go go go go
go go can't see [ __ ] can't see [ __ ]
can't see [ __ ] open the goddamn door
yeah [ __ ] okay okay could this was not
it what is this then who is who's this
other contained person there's another
containment thing in here who is 966
I've never heard of nine six six
sentient and violent but I have no idea
okay I'm gonna go back this way I think
I can make it past that area where no 96
was at least now anyway I just want to
be able to get to a safe point that's
all I want in life right now that's
literally the only thing I want is this
a point like please see here he's not
here okay so he's made his way out of
here
good okay that's fine that's fine that's
fine fuel pump on on okay that's nice
that's nice
generator
okay good no computer terminal there
which is [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] kill
me please I'm I've come so far nearby
dead end over here okay please tell me
this has biohazard oh [ __ ] hi okay I'll
get that in a second you just need to
make sure [ __ ] Billy doesn't come in
there nothing happened Jesus okay I'm
gonna put on this suit before I die
because I have a funny feeling I'm gonna
die exposed to this area put on the
hazmat suit which is good
god damnit what do i do oh eight I've
never heard of 0:08 either I can't find
a [ __ ] computer terminal to say my
life and it probably will save my life
okay so so Billy is right on top of me
where where where where [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
where where where where where is he is
he in this room get my practice on well
okay well the hazmat suits gonna scare
me some day he's right here or not okay
oh don't go okay all right then Lau's
dumb of you
[ __ ] you don't do that don't do that
don't do that don't do that don't do
that don't do that so where do I go I've
been everywhere and I can't [ __ ] fun
I can't [ __ ] find a single terminal
with which to thrust my data
I don't know man I don't know guys I
don't know I don't know what's going
being a mega dick to me
I've made so much progress and I just
haven't been able to find a goddamn save
I'm trying to make my way back to the
only save I've seen last which was the
it was the area where I put the gas mask
back on lose the area through here see
if there's anything in here yep yep oh
nine six is somewhere here that's okay
while I'm here going here or this area
no not do that
yeah it's not good yeah that's that's
the opposite of good
so 173 is nearby people see him he's got
to be a computer room I know there was a
computer I'm just over here rubber ducky
over there which is fine and this was
nothing freaky don't honk at me you
squonk e bastard I don't like none of it
please I'm begging you begging you I'm
begging you I'm begging you I'm begging
and begging it wasn't there one in here
there was wasn't it yes okay
[ __ ] finally my god oh yeah why
aren't there any safe points why why
aren't there any I got no idea why
aren't there any I don't know the [ __ ]
man [ __ ] oh man there's just no se
points okay but I'm in a really good
place right now why did I have this in
my thing I don't need this anymore so
I'm in a really good place right now
I've been playing for about two hours I
want to take a break cuz one my voice
has been really fragile lately I don't
know I don't feel sick which is really
weird but my voice has been really
fragile so I'm going to take a break
right here but I definitely want to pick
this up again either in a live format or
not I want to do this again but in
closing I'm gonna read some comments
that have that have been waiting for me
so just yeah thank you guys so much for
being here with me if you got any
comments I want to read them yes a point
yay I did it okay so yeah I don't know
what's been going on with my voice it's
it's been super weird I'm not sick yeah
I'm not sick
yeah mark is brave I don't think that's
that's brave
no look if you hit f5 save is only
permitted on clickable monitor scattered
throughout the series so I cannot save I
cannot save unless you're at a computer
terminal so see blap-blap-blap pressing
f5 yeah oh that sounds bad okay so Oh
Draco Phoenix said mark if you wouldn't
mind I'd like to make a gamer's request
for more nostalgic purposes and you get
diplomatic bragging rights you still
don't have to get normal begging RAC
your rights
oh you still have to get normal bragging
rights like to request to play a game
shinobi for ps2 and it's on ps3 I don't
think I've ever played shinobi for some
reason I thought of Shenmue when you
said of shinobi and SHINee and move I
love that game a long time ago does he
pyew nerf bros thank you for everything
I wish Oh third time to do this I wish I
never get noticed please my twitter name
is a per nas me okay I see alright so
thank you for that and chain-gun dragon
says almost four years ago your draw my
life inspired me to start my own channel
even if no one watches them I've really
enjoyed making videos so I kind of owe
you that much so thank you so much Kevin
Aragon says I'm so happy to see you
playing SCP again you should check out
an RPG horn a game called Kiyo's
adventure when you have a chance
breather the great said hey mark thank
you for inspiring me to make my own
channel I found you from your sender
Slender Man series I'm happy I did
thanks well thank you very much and
congratulations Marcin deflower says hey
mark thank you so much for everything
you've done for us I hope to meet you in
person in real life too thank you soon
and if I you go on the tour maybe you
will let's see
Rose Arashi says you are one of my
absolute favorite youtubers of all time
you're the perfect mix of entertaining
and sweet also if you please say Rosa
Rashi pronounced air ah she is best girl
you will be my favorite well thank you
very much I hope I got that correctly I
think I butchered it completely but
thank you again and then Jean Nicholas
caress says sunday is my birthday it's
also easier so everyone join me remember
everyone join me happy birthday to you
and that's it that's all I can do for
now but happy birthday swag awesome says
you did it you did it
vii sword says yo mark I started
watching you back during cry fear and
you've held me through some very trying
times I was inspired to start my own
channel and my goal is to one day do a
collab with you if and when my channel
becomes worthy enough well that's the
thing that a lot of people a lot of
people ask they're like oh I hope to do
a collab when my when my when my channel
becomes worthy and us but it's not it's
not a thing of worth to me like collabs
I tried to do as few as possible and I
try to deal with them with people that
are very close friends of mine but what
I do do is I play games with people that
I've met casually that's where that's
where I play games and I feel like you
can't become friends with it alone if
you start out by like hey let's collab
and you know the only point where you
get like collapse that are worth good
content is where you play games with
people and I want to play those games
and I want
do that more and I want to like play
games of the community and play
multiplayer games that I can play with
you guys I want to do that a lot more
both on stream on video and not on
streams so that that's what's important
to me so DJ skits says thank you for
everything you do can you visit Chicago
I'm sure will come to Chicago someplace
because sometime because Chicago is like
the number one improv city in the world
it's where like a lot of improv errs go
to learn and where a lot of improv so
given that I I'm learning improv and I
love it
I want to go there dog bite says it's so
awesome to see more SVP from you I've
been watching you for four years and
you've helped me through a lot thanks
for everything thank you
kiara McKenzie says you can you please
play dungeon nightmares to also been
watching since 2013 I remember I played
that didn't I
it was that the demo did I only play the
demo and the full game got released I
have no idea Nash sue said remember the
Alamo Nyx's start hi Anna said I have
actually made my own SCP creature called
frac Fox let me know if you see it I'll
look it up do you Gorillaz dinara says
do you ever play games you stop playing
on your channel like stardew valley for
example yeah often times when i when i
don't do a series of a game i'll play it
on my own because i think the game's fun
kitty life says SCP was the first years
i watched from you and i've been
watching ever since i'm sure you're so
busy so thank you for taking your time
out of your day to do this then this
algid was super overwhelming well
obviously III wanted to do this because
I thought it would make a great change
up to the day and like make this Friday
a little special and thank you everybody
so much for being here with me the D of
the DVR the DVR the [ __ ] numb the
this video this stream will be uploaded
as a normal video afterwards very soon
kay Potter just at mouth surgery you're
making recovery left awful so thank you
Kay Potter for watching I appreciate
that
Margaret nine six six is an SCP that
will kill you by destroying your mental
state you need the emerald ring or
you'll die advanced oh oh one said that
well that's very important I need to
find the emerald ring I did not know
that [ __ ] I'm gonna die Frick
let's see Jenna and diamonds so glad I
caught the stream gutentag from
Deutschland guten tag guten abend if
it's evening over there I think
it's a fear crawler your videos are my
happy place when not doing scary stories
on my channel ironic considering you
play a lot of scary games fist bump
bomb brother fast let's see plar BD
planet visiting Portland Oregon I do
I've heard it's a great city your enemy
said so my dad just got out of heart
surgery and he wanted me to make sure
you know that me and him love your
videos and he's gonna be watching
through your entire recovery well best
of luck to your dad I hope he gets
better very soon I know that's a rough
surgery but he just got out and if you
know I if he's doing better than he's on
the road to recovery so wish him the
best for me let's see mark you need to
use the suit to close the door in the
SCP 0:08 chamber so if I use the suit
then close the door I was in a bit of a
panic so I wasn't able to think clearly
about that one so sanguine rows to 3 to
4 said you would kill the play a game
casually with you mark I want to do that
III haven't had time to play a lot of
games lately I haven't even really had
time to play overwatch or whatever but
you know I want to do I want to do a lot
more so I I will do that very soon Paul
Brown said mark I saw you played a game
to the moon but I was wondering if you
were gonna play a bird story as well is
that like a sequel or something to it
because I'd love to play that that
sounds good
husky hickman says have you played
stellaris it's a space game check it out
ok I will
and with that I am out of time I gotta
get going I'm gonna record subnautica
for later today we're gonna have another
video that come in very soon so thank
you everybody so much for joining me on
this adventure I'm gonna be playing more
SCP containment breach either in a
livestream setting or in normal videos
so thanks again everybody and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
bye guys bye bye I'm gonna say bye for a
good long time so that I don't cut it
off prematurely at the when this turns
into a normal video or otherwise this is
gonna be me saying bye for a while on
the video and then it's gonna be weird
so bye anyway and good bye good bye guys
bye good bye i'm a boudreaux bye good
you fare well fare thee well
good bye ladies and the Gentiles means